our subject for today and god said what
did i say
and god said is our subject for this
evening
in the beginning
god created the heaven and the earth
and the earth was without form and void
and darkness was upon the face of the
deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters
and god said
let there be light
and there was light
and god saw the light that it was good
and god divided the light from the
darkness
and god called the light day and the
darkness he called night
and evening and morning
with the first day
for by him
were all things created
that are in heaven and that are in earth
visible and invisible
whether they be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers all things were
created by him and for him and he is
before all things and by him all things
consist
so remember the sabbath day to keep it
holy
six days shall thou labor and do all thy
work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the lord thy god
in it thou shalt not do any work
thou
not my son
nor thy daughter thy man's servant not
thy maidservant not a cattle
not a stranger that is within thy gates
for in six days the lord made heaven and
earth the sea and all that in there is
and rested the seventh day
wherefore the lord blessed the sabbath
day
and hallowed it
for the lord is good
his mercy is everlasting
and his truth endureth to all
generations and i thank god
for the everlasting nature of truth amen
it endures
to all generations whether those
generations are human generations or
divine generations god's truth will
exist
as long as god exists
because jesus said i am the way
the truth
and their life first john chapter 5
verse 6 the spirit
is truth deuteronomy 32 4 god is a god
of truth
father is truth
son is truth
spirit is truth if we are members of the
family of god we must be children of
truth
this
is truth amen
thus saith the lord
and the word of god means so much to him
the bible says in psalm 138 verse 2 thou
has magnified
thy word
above all thy name
and the bible offers about 300 different
names for god each of them teaching us
something about god
god says to the spirit
my word is above all my names combined
i thank god for his word the word saves
it does everything
i say again good morning everyone
and i welcome those who are connecting
online wherever you are may the lord
bless you as abundantly as we believe he
will bless us today on this holy day
most people are going about their
business right now
on god's holy day
god does not function by majority he
functions by his word and his word says
the seventh day is the sabbath and if
the whole world says anything else it
does not change thus saith the lord and
so as you and i worship on this earth on
the holy day we know that there's also
rejoicing in heaven because the church
on earth is simply an extension of the
church in heaven amen
you say amen but let me say it again
the church on earth
is merely an extension of the church in
heaven why do i say that the bible tells
us clearly our father which art in
heaven hallowed be thy name thy kingdom
come now say the rest with me thy will
be done where
how's in heaven
and what is the will of god the ten
commandments
psalm 103 20 bless the lord ye his
angels that excel in strength that do
his commandments
i say again as we worship on earth on
the holy day
there is rejoicing in heaven because the
church on earth is merely an extension
of the church in heaven and there's one
preacher one pastor and that is jesus
christ
that's enough of that is there anyone
with us today for the very first time
you are not a seventh-day adventist
mercy your hand is my custom to ask oh
the whole church is visiting all right
would you kind will someone represent
you and tell us who you are
a congregation
typically meets in centerville yes
amen okay for those of you online who
may not have heard we have a
congregation that meets on sabbath not
saying the evidence but they recognize
the law of god and we're fellowshipping
together with them and we are pleased
and proud
to have you with us and may the lord
bless you beyond your expectation and
put a double blessing on your children
for those of you online god bless you
god bless you god bless you ceaselessly
our subject for today and god said what
did i say and god said is our subject
for this evening i always ask you to
preserve reverence and you have done
that not because i have asked but
because i believe you respect god and
may the lord bless you for that but if
you're using one of these simply make
sure it does not ring that's all i'm
asking i hope that's a reasonable
request
let me check mine it is off
and so i go to favor number two while
i'm speaking i want you to say lord put
your words in that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i have
put my words in thy mouth and favor
number three think as you listen
isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason
together said the lord so as i speak
think and the lord will bless that
thinking process let us pray
our father in heaven we thank you for
the gift of life
we thank you thank god we can come into
your presence without molestation from
the authorities
we thank you father for physical ability
to move from point a to b
we thank you we left homes to come to
this place
we have transportation
we have food
we have freedom of worship
dear god
our thankfulness can extend all during
the day and never end
we're just grateful to you father
for all that you do most of which we do
not even recognize but we thank you
nonetheless
we thank you for angels that protect us
from a thousand different angels
we thank you for the holy spirit that
taps us on the shoulder and tells us
don't do that
and we thank you lord for the blood of
christ that still circles this earth
as we borrow your presence if we have
sinned
forgive us
your only problem with us day god
is sin
if we've offended you forgive us
particularly me because my burden and i
use the word burden dear god is to
deliver the words of life and i am flesh
i am dirt
help me to god i pray for your own sake
and then for the blessing of your people
bless those online in a very special way
father bless this country
guide the minds of the leaders that i
pray and all the countries represented
by those watching online bless the
leaders as well they god remind them
father
that righteousness exalteth a nation
father if anyone listening to me has
quote 19 heal that person dear god heal
that person i pray because your god of
mercy now father
i commit this service to your glory
glorify yourself through the truth in
jesus name i pray let god's people say
amen and amen what's our subject
you took too long to answer what's the
subject
all right
genesis 1 let's read from verse 1
i read from the king james version of
the bible
genesis 1 reading first one it's 10
minutes after 11 i will release you
before all by 12 noon unless the holy
spirit tells me otherwise
genesis 1 reading from first one do you
have that
yes if you have my version you may read
with me
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth
and the earth was without form and void
and darkness was upon the face of the
deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters
and
god one
sense stop
and god
said
look at verse six
read the first four words
of verse three
and
god said
look at verse 9 the first three words
look at verse 11 the first three words
where you have the king james and god
look at verse 14 the first three words
and god said look at verse 20 the first
three words and god said look at 24 the
first three words and god said look at
26 the first three words and god said
for every day of creation what do we
read and god said let me say that
differently for every day of creation
what do we encounter
the word of god the voice of god the
word of god for every
day of creation we are introduced again
to the word of god
now
having seen that in the very first
chapter of the bible we ask ourselves
what is god trying to tell us by having
the writer of genesis moses
consistently repeat and god say and god
said what is god trying to teach us
in the very first chapter of the bible
this
that we live by every word this is how
we must live
because this is how whatever we see came
into existence
are you with me
having a look to genesis 1 let's go to
psalm 33
we read 6 and 9 our subject and god said
genesis 6 genesis 33 sorry
6-9
genesis 33
do you have that
as usual
nobody answered the preacher do you have
that
all right
you have genesis 33
you have verse 6
read with me
by the word of the lord where the
heavens made and all the hosts of them
by the breath of his mouth nine for he
spake and it was done he commanded and
it stood
are you reading with me
33 6 and 9.
oh did i say genesis
why didn't someone say something
ah you broke my heart say something
say lord jesus preacher let's go psalm
33 no wonder you look as confused as i
look by looking at you
psalm 33 let's read for six tell me if
you're there now amen all right one
person is there anybody else
all right two okay let's read together
now by the word of the lord were the
heavens made and all the hosts of them
by the breath of his mouth stopped what
do we what are we to understand by all
the hosts of them
let the bible tell us go to psalm 148.
our subject and god said psalm
we're trying to understand what it's
meant by
and all the hosts of them
psalms 148
yeah what did i say you said psalm 1 48.
oh okay
148.
i need to learn the english spoken in uh
chestertown different from michigan all
right psalm 148
are you with me now
let's read from first one first one
i'll let you get it
yeah do you have it now yeah let me pray
again fathers i continue speaking to
your beautiful people and as i speak for
you
you speak through me in jesus name i
pray amen
praise you the lord
praising the lord from the heavens
praise him in the heights praising him
all these angels praising him
always else
hosts angels are part of the hosts of
heaven
so when we read in psalm 33 4 6 by the
word of the lord of the heavens men and
all the hosts of them it is not simply
sun moon and stars it also made the
angelic inhabitants in heaven they were
made by the word of god look at verse
five
of psalm 148 are you there let them
praise the name of the lord why for he
commanded come on and they were created
angels are very powerful beings very
very powerful
when an angel came down to the tomb of
christ the entire roman guard fell as if
they were dead and there was an
earthquake the bible says in matthew 28
from verse 2 to 4 one angel came down
there was an earthquake when he touched
down all the hardened professional roman
soldiers when they saw them they fainted
one
all angels were made simply by the
spoken word of god and so sometime in
the distant past god said let there be
angels and angels just came how
the word
by his word
that thing you're holding in your hand
i don't mean
paper
and ink
i mean the word of god is that clear
this is paper
that black thing is ink
i'm referring to the word of god because
when god spoke there was no egg and
there was no paper
but we still have that word
what's our subject
and god said now
when adam opened his eyes
he saw creation
i am sure the father told him
or the creator told him how everything
was made by god's word
do you think adam fully understood how
that happened
no
but what do you think was his response
to god's word
he
adam looked accepted
and the creator told him that tree was
made by my word and adam accepted it
because the foundation of sin
is not believing god and so we disobey
his law
adam
accepted creation
on the basis of the word of god even
though he could not explain how it
happened amen amen that's creation
you and i we look up everyday
at night we see the stars and every
night if you're an astronomer you
realize there's certain heavenly bodies
that are in the certain position at
certain times of the year certain times
of the same position and we wonder how
does that happen
by the word of god
which means
we have to live because since we cannot
explain
how someone can speak
and a dead man can get a brother lazarus
what must be our reaction to god's word
give me one word
i heard it say it loudly
faith
because we cannot we're explanation is
easy faith is not required that's why
the bible is a book of evidence not
proof
i didn't say that clearly let me try
again
the bible is a book of
evidence you see evidence must be
followed and traced and if you follow
and trace honestly you'll be led to the
correct conclusion the bible is the book
of evidence so faith is required
where there's proof
there's no need for faith
and so as we study creation we must
approach it how by faith let the bible
tell us that now go to hebrews chapter
11 let's read verse three our subject
and god said we're looking at god's word
hebrews 11.
did i say that correctly
all right hebrews 11
3 verse 3
i'll miss you and i'm gone i really will
as quiet as you are i'll miss you
you have hebrews 11 verse 3 are you
there
read with me through faith we understand
that the worlds were framed by the word
of god stop
through faith by faith in what
the word of god
with our faith we can never understand
through faith we understand now the
scientific method says let me understand
first
are you following me
then i believe
let me prove it in a lab that i believe
let me see the results of the bunsen
burner and i believe god's system is no
no no no no no start with faith and so
the bible says through faith we
understand that the world's refrain an
astronomer who really wants to advance
in his or her field ought to begin with
faith
we do not understand creation fully
and so we come in faith because faith is
an expression of dependence and trust
now having said that let's move from
physical creation by the word of god
let's go to spiritual creation let's go
to john chapter three
our subject and god said john chapter
three
if you have a child next to you help the
child to find those books
excellent time to train children how to
find the books of the bible
do you have john chapter 3
verse 8
let me pray again father please continue
to speak through me i appeal to you in
jesus name amen read with me the wind
bleweth where it listeth and now here's
the sound thereof but can't not tell
whence it cometh or whether it goes so
is everyone finish the verse that is
born of the spirit what is jesus
referring to by born of the spirit
the word of the spirit the clues in the
word born born of the spirit
again
[Music]
that
justified by
faith now jesus said the same way you do
not understand how what
how the wind blows is the wind part of
creation yes or no yes come on say yes
with confidence even if you're wrong are
you with me
do you understand how the world grows
yes or no yeah
that is how no you don't
no you don't
[Music]
christ is using the physical level
now he goes to the spiritual he says
that's the same way it functions
spiritually you cannot explain
conversion
but how is conversion done go to first
peter chapter one
we just saw born again in john three
verse eight the new birth we saw in john
the bible is uh inspired by one spirit
he does not contradict himself first
peter chapter 1 verse 23 are you there
so i'm used to looking
have you found it now
now if you have my version read with me
what does that say being
born again stop
then we see born again in john 8
yes we saw it
so is everyone that is
born of the spirit
now peter says be born again not of
corruptible seed but what
important was that incredible by the
word of god come on that he lives and
abideth forever how are we born again by
the word of god but we need more proof
of james chapter one just before first
peter just before first peter is james
james one james was a half brother of
jesus he must have known jesus quite
well so this is the breath of jesus
speaking read verse 18 of james chapter
one what does that say
of his own will be get here stop what
does beget mean
to give birth yes
so we have born in john 3 8 we have born
in first peter chapter 1 verse 23 now we
have born again in james 118. what does
james say of his own will began he has
how come on read the verse
with the word of jesus
this
is what brings about
the new birth
this
is what brought about physical life
this is what brings about spiritual life
and so jesus says let's go to matthew 1
4 matthew chapter 4
we just concluded correctly the words
god produced physical life the word of
god brings spiritual life
having established that biblically let's
go in matthew chapter four we read from
verse one our subject and god said
it's 25 after 11
we have 35 minutes to go at maximum
do you have matthew chapter 4
from verse 1
then was jesus led up of the spirit into
the wilderness to be tempted of the
devil
and when he fasted 40 days and 40 nights
he was afterward and hungered
and when the tempter came to him he said
if thou be the son of god command these
stones we made bread breathe first for
with me but he answered and said why it
is written stop is that what we're
discussing today it is written yes it is
written phrase the verse man shall not
live by bread alone but by every word
that procedure out of the mouth of god
question for you
tell me when you're ready for the
question
all right
notice the words of christ read
microscopically man shall not what
live
by bread alone now how many ways are
they to live
one
two i get it
what are the two bread and the word okay
let's say that differently
bread represents what kind of life
physics ah you live physically
what's the other way to live
i give you an a for adventists yes you
live physically by the bread or you live
spiritually by the same bread and
spiritual level now jesus said
man shall not live by the lord whether
physical or spiritual
he has to live
come on talk to me
by the word of
there are god christians
who live physically
but not spiritually
because they're so busy
finish my words
they're so busy tell me what i'm about
to say
and the most important way to live
is not physical
it's spiritual
[Music]
how do you cast out demons in this word
how do you raise the letters for this
word
if the word is
listen to this verse don't go there just
listen
she that liveth in pleasure
is dead why is she living
that woman who must be in the bar
the club or that man every weekend or
every night
he's dead on the dance floor
why he or she's dancing
because the person is only living
physically
but the spinal cord of physical life
is spiritual
amen
and so jesus said to the satan
man shall not live
by bread alone
but by every word
that proceedeth out of the mouth of god
what's our subject
and
god said
and so the bible says
in hebrews 11 6 go there with me
hebrews 11
verse 6. you know it well let's read it
11 30 on the dot
do you have that
my friends online i hope you're still
with us
read with me but without faith
it is impossible to please him now stop
go to romans 10
romans 10 then we come back to uh
hebrews 11 romans 10.
let's read verse 17 of romans 10.
you have that
all right read 17 with me come on what
does it say
romans 10 17 what does that say
we must put two verses together
what did hebrews 11 6 say without
faith
it is impossible to please god
paul tells us faith coming by hearing
and hearing by the word of god what two
things do we have that must always go
together hearing in the word of god okay
hearing the word
but here's what
the word you cannot separate faith from
the word of god remove the word of god
no one can exercise faith
because faith
is a response to thus saith the lord i'm
talking about saving faith and so the
bible tells us without
faith
without what
say differently without
trusting
without leaning your full weight upon
god's word
you cannot
please
god now
let's look at our ultimate example who's
that person quickly
jesus let's go to john 8.
john 8
we've discovered you can't please god
without faith we've discovered faith is
our response to god's word now listen to
jesus john 8 29.
are you there
read with me what does that say listen
to jesus but he that have sent me
is with me
the father hath not left me alone why
for i know always those saints come on
that please him now keep john 8 29 in
mind and hebrews 11 6 listen to hebrews
11 6 just listen
without faith
it is impossible to
that's a negative in other words then
how do we please god
by showing faith are you with me do you
say that
how do we displease god
by not acting by faith you see every
time i sing i have
let go my faith in god
you cannot sin and exercise faith at the
same time
you're not with me
you cannot sin
and exercise faith in the word at the
same time because faith releases power
every time we sin in that moment we have
released our faith hold on jesus christ
now
without faith
you cannot please god but jesus said in
john 8 29 i do always the things that
please him what does that tell you about
jesus
he lived a life finished my words of
faith
in his humanity
and faith is what
jesus lived
by the same lord
in his divinity he was the world
in his humanity he lived by the world
that's how we all live
go to genesis 7.
let me show you another example of that
someone less than jesus but a tremendous
example genesis 7
let's read first one
our subject and god said
do you have genesis 7
verse 1
are we ready
and god said unto noah come thou
and all thy house into the ark for thee
have i seen what
righteous before whom
me
now your friends may not see you as
righteous
they may not see you as good
they may not see you as holy they may
see you as crackpots and strange
because you worship on a day most people
ignore but how they see you is not as
important as how
god sees you
and so i said noah
you have unseen righteous in my sight
your husband may think you're mad
because you've decided to keep us out
god thinks you're sane
thee have i seen righteous before me
so god said of noah you're righteous now
go to second peter chapter two
quickly quickly quickly
second peters have to you're too young
to be so slow come on
chapter two
let's read from verse four
all right 25 minutes to 12.
do you have second peter
chapter 2
verse 4 read with me for if god spared
not the angels that sinned but cast them
down to hell and delivered them into the
chains of darkness to be reserved until
judgment now fine i don't hear you
reading fine and spared not the old
world but save noah the eighth person
briefly that's your words a preacher of
righteousness stop let's put two verses
together again
how did god describe noah in genesis 7
1. you're righteous what does the holy
spirit say of noah in second peter 2
verse 5
he's a preacher of righteousness now put
those two things together
what was his character in genesis 7 1
what did he preach in 1725
he walked and he talked
he walked the walk come on
and talk the talk
that's the way we ought to be
a lot of us we talk the talk
and the case is closed
jesus christ
he talked the talk
he walked the walk
and the only way to walk in a way that
pleases god is to walk in accordance
with thus saith the lord go to first
john chapter two let's read verse six
to establish that point
first john chapter two verse six
our subject and god said
you have first john 2
verse 6
read with me if you have my version he
that says he abideth in him finish the
verse ought himself also so to walk
even as he walked
who's the he
jesus
what's the bible saying and this book
was written by the disciple closest to
christ john john he said look if you say
you have a relationship with christ you
should live the way he lives
and how did jesus live by the word of
god
so when the devil said command these
stones to be made bread jesus said it is
written
you see the devil has a word
and god has
won ah you're not with me
i'm talking to myself
listen again
god has
and it is written
the devil has and it is written
you look at me strangely
let the bible help you out and me
let's go to genesis chapter two
we're looking for it is written from the
devil it is written from god
or it is said by god it is said by satan
genesis chapter 2 let's read verse 16 or
verse 17 then we'll skip over to chapter
three are you there
father in heaven as i continued in god
restrain me
use me father often no resistance in
jesus name amen
verse 16 verse 17 of genesis 2 was the
bible saying and the lord god commanded
the man saying of every tree of the
garden thou may freely eat but of the
tree of the knowledge of good and evil
thou shalt not eat of it finish that
verse
foreign thou shalt surely die for words
who said them
god
thou shall surely die that is thus saith
the lord or it is written from god let's
go to chapter three
from verse one
now the servant was more subtle than any
beast of the field which the lord god
had made
have you said yeah as god said you shall
not eat of every tree of the garden
and the woman said unto the servant we
may eat of the fruit of the trees of the
garden but of the fruit of the tree
which is in the midst of the garden god
has said you shall not evade neither
shall he touch unless you die and the
serpent said unto the woman you tell me
you shall not surely die god said four
he said five okay
now we have two words the word of god
the word of sin
god said if you sin
you die the devil said if you sin you
live
you didn't
[Music]
life so god said if you sin by eating
you die
what's the devil say if you eat
you live
up to today
people still
live by the devil's word instead of gods
listen to me carefully
here's thus saith the lord
remember the sabbath day to keep it holy
six days shall thou labor and do all thy
work
but the seventh day is the sabbath of
the law of thy god that is it
is written that is thus saith the lord
that is am god said
in 3 21
300 years lucky after christ died an
emperor called constantine
passed a law
telling people to rest on sunday
and work on saturday
in 364 a church council called the
council of louisville it passed a law
called canon 29
making it illegal to observe the south
and anyone who deals with the anatomy
which means you cast out of christ if
you keep the bible sabbath now what did
god say remember the sabbath day which
is the seventh day was the voice say
sunday
and most of the world finish my words
follow the other voice
now let's go back to eden
it's 20 to 12.
i hope you don't notice if i sleep five
minutes past twelve don't look
let's go back to genesis the garbage
this is very important
i want you to listen with your heart
more than your head but with both but
your eyes
eve opened her eyes
adam opened his eyes when the reverse
order animals made first
did they see creation yes or no
yes did they see trees yes
sky the sun they felt the breeze
they saw the animal brightly colored
birds flying through the branches they
saw the fish fluttering in the waters
all of that was proof
that something had power what's that
god's word because they were all made by
and they'll say are you with me
stay with me
they were surrounded
by evidence
that god's word
has power
now that same god said
in the day that we this thereof
thou shall surely die
they were standing in a world surrounded
by evidence
that thou shalt surely die is as
reliable as let the earth bring forth
grace
now here comes the devil
and he offers his word
he shall not surely die
they had
no evidence
that that word
had power
none
that word did not make the trees
did not make the grass did not make the
animals did not make the sun did not
make the stars did not make the fish the
birds the sunlight it made nothing
so here is eve with all the evidence
god's word has power no evidence the
devil's word has power whose word does
she choose
before you look down your nose at eve
let's look down our noses at ourselves
and let's look up our noses
there isn't one bible verse that says
the first day of the week is the sound
not one
you didn't hear me
i said
not one
not one incy bincy
first and yet
finish my word
the most of the world
honors the day
god does not require
when you live by
if
and god said
the seventh day
is the summer
eve's behavior
has come down to this present day
let me tell you something about
disobedience
it it so
deforms the mind that the mind becomes
almost impossible to recognize truth
listen to me carefully
what's the color of this phone
black
when you've been conditioned to believe
it is white
even though it's black
when someone shows you black what will
you say
why
even though you see come on
black what will you say
why
because you're in condition
the bible says the central day
you show it
and people still say what
the first thing
even though they see
39 and i'll let you go
we'll conclude and god's head luke 5
37-39 this time i want you to read with
me and you don't read with me
you're free i don't know why
yeah this is the last day to read with
me
if you have my version
do you have luke 5
i don't know what to do to get you to
read with me but uh
i've given up hope
all right
are you luke 5.
father in heaven am i call and come to
the close day god but don't close off
your assistance to me in jesus name i
pray amen
no man put it one
new wine where it all bothers else the
new wine will
burst the bottles and be
and the bottle shall
perish okay don't put new wine in old
bottles what christ is saying my new
teachings won't make sense in the old
bottle of your soul you need a
conversion are you following me you need
to be a new bottle to understand when
i'm teaching you the new wine now verse
38 but your wine come on now we put in
new bottles and
both are preserved
now listen to 39 carefully
tell me when you're ready
no man also having drunk
old wine that's the old teaching
what's the next word straightway
desireth new
pause
people who've grown in error does not do
not immediately design the truth one
first verse for he says what
the old is better
my old way
is better
the traditions of my family are better
even though i do not have one
bible verse
when i read that with a broken heart i
think of john 3 verse 19 go with me and
then let me let you go again that's
twice i'm saying that
john 3 19.
do you have it
i recommend it john for you i hope
you'll take time to read the entire
gospel
and understand why it's so important by
reading chapter 20 verse 13 31 but don't
do that now john 3 verse 19 read with me
what does this say
and this is the condemnation
what do you mean by condemnation
the death sentence
that light is come into the world give
me another word for light
truth in the birth of christ and his
word this is the condemnation that light
is come into the world keep reading and
men
love darkness come on
bear their light why
because it is
reverse 20
for everyone that
does evil hated the light
neither constant life unless this being
shall be reproved have
did i tell you the story i was doing a
crusade outside detroit i don't know if
i told you maybe i did if i did i'll
tell you again
i literally came every night for the
first week we were there for three weeks
we met every night after the first week
i didn't see her i called her at the
office and i said i haven't seen you she
said
i can't come back
i said why
she said i cannot sit under that
preaching and not make a decision
so i'm not coming back oh wow
that's why she told me there's a god in
heaven who knows i'm telling the truth i
cannot sit under that and not make a
decision i'm not coming back i don't
want
very nice lady
but being nice is not what saves you
it's the righteousness of christ and the
righteousness of christ is the
righteousness of the law of god she
decided i am not coming back jesus said
no man no woman having drunk old wine
straight where desire is new sometimes
it takes time to show people the bible
says two and two and four because
they've been trained two and two may 22
and you have a difference of time
and i think of jesus who said why do you
not understand my speech even because
you cannot hear my word jesus was just
puzzled how is it
because you cannot understand what i'm
saying
what is he saying
man shall not live like alone finish it
but by every word my brothers and
sisters thus saith the lord
is the way to live a life that pleases
god no i'm not speaking about genuine
ignorance
let me tell you what genuine ignorance
is
i didn't know
and i had no way of knowing
that's genuine ignorance
i didn't know
i had nothing
what's your subject
and god said
thou shalt have know the gods before me
make god
your only god not your career
not your boyfriend your girlfriend your
husband your wife your children your
money made god your only god
two and god said thou shalt not make
unto thee any grievan image do not have
images in your life and false doctrines
is an image
because it is placed ahead of truth and
jesus is truth let me say again false
doctrine is an image
and god said thou shalt not take the
name of the lord thy god in vain don't
say one thing and do something else and
then embarrass god
and god said remember the sabbath day
rekeep god's holy day it's his
sunday is not a holy day
no it's tuesday wednesday thursday
friday
they are not holy days they've never
been they're not now
and god said unto thy father thy mother
your father is first and foremost god
not the pope
your holy father
is god
and god said thou shalt not kill
don't kill
don't destroy people's reputations don't
destroy the hopes of a child in your
classroom by telling your child he or
she is too big
[Music]
and god said thou shalt not commit
adultery spiritual adultery is worse
than physical because it is truth
that's why babylon committed adultery
with the kings of the nations era and
truth
don't do that
and god said thou shalt not steal
return god's tithe
is this microphone working
thou shalt not bear false witness
against thy neighbor don't misrepresent
your neighbor let your neighbor be able
to rely on you
and god said
thou shalt not covet
a lot of us are in debt because we want
everything everybody else has
we see this and we want it we see that
and we want it she has that i want it he
has that i want it thou shalt not come
let me tell you commandment 10 is
defense against death
amen
and god said
man shall not live by bread alone but by
every word
is there a word of god
by which you and i are not living
faithfully let me say it differently
is this something god requires of us we
know it
and we don't do it
let me say differently is there a sin in
our lives
that we will not confess
i ask you now in the name of jesus
confess it
privately
make a commitment to your god father
here is an area of my life that is not
lived according to every word
i want that change
because that single area can destroy any
hope i have of a place in your eternal
kingdom i want that area shut down their
god and i want to live in harmony with
your will as you have revealed to me
let me shorten my appeal
you're doing something you know it's
wrong
you need to stop
i say it again
there's something in our lives we're
doing that is wrong we know it
we need to stop
because if you don't stop
god will stop you
don't let god stop you
the bible says humble yourself
if god humbles you
you will not like it
if god has to stop you you will not like
it
and so exercise all the wisdom you have
stop yourself
is there a woman who will say father
there's something i've been doing i need
to stop it
and i make that decision today by your
power
to stop and to live my life as far as i
can
by thus said the lord is there someone
like that can i see your hand there's
something i need to stop
it might not be murder it may be just
jealousy it may be whatever there's
something i need to stop
let me see that happen don't look around
to see who's raising i'm talking to you
stand up with me
i have another question for you listen
carefully
there's someone you need to forgive
you haven't done it
jesus says forgive us our debts how
as we forgive do you understand
an unforgiving person cannot be saved
unforgiveness is condemned by calvary's
cross
there's someone you need to forgive
you have not forgiven i'm calling upon
you today make a decision to forgive
that person and release yourself from
prison
several years ago i was speaking
somewhere speaking and this lady walked
out of the service in a huff
and several weeks later she sent me an
email to explain i never know this when
she left
she said while you were preaching i left
i was preaching about forgiveness it was
a week of prayer like this
she said there's a sister another blood
sister a step sister who treated me
badly my father remarried and
he loved her more than me whatever the
story was and i left the house i was
homeless anyway she made herself to
another country she had established
herself but for decades she hated that
stepsister
when i preached forgiveness she couldn't
take it she walked up but she said the
holy ghost walked up with me
and chased me all the way to my house
and would not leave me alone because god
wants to save her
and she was so convicted she decided to
try to find this sister she had not seen
for over 20 years
finally found the contact number called
her
only to discover
that sister had become a seventh-day
adventist
i was trying to find her
to say sorry
she said in the email we cried and cried
and cried on the phone
and the subheading of her email was
i
am free
i was in another country counseling
young people this young lady came to me
i hate my father
i said you shouldn't hate your father i
hate my father he had remarried and the
stepdaughter he loved the step-daughter
more than the biological so she thought
and she said i'm failing my classes
they're hurting
i hate my father i said you have to
forgive your father no
i said my young sister you must forgive
your father she said no
you know hatred is a certain kind of
power hatred is a negative power but it
kills you are you following me hatred is
our power it makes you strong to kill
yourself
i say we pray let's nail we both know
i said you pray first forgive your
father
i shall not like this
my eyes open watching you
and the tears are coming i said pray
and forgive your father
i said i'll pray i'll tell you what to
say
father in heaven father in heaven
forgive my father for i said that and
she
i say
father i forgive my father what is done
and i say you have to say it whether you
feel it or not god does not function by
feeling say i forget and she said i
forget my father she cried again
then i closed off the prayer
a few weeks later she wrote me
she said i want you to know
i'm a different person
amen have you forgiven my father
i am a different person all together
there is someone you need to forgive
the person to criticize your hairstyle
or your shoe
or your children
and you've carried a cancerous grudge
let it go today
and save yourself
i've never seen anyone destroyed by
somebody else's envy
envy destroys you hatred destroys you
the grass destroys the person who
carries it do you not understand that
all right
here's bob eyes closed
before i pray
someone listening may need to make a
decision to be baptized
or re-baptized
because of what has happened in your
life this week someone may need to make
that decision to be baptized or
re-baptized heads bowed eyes closed
fought in heaven
thank you for your word
we thank you for it is written
we thank you for and
god
said amen
father we live in a world created by and
god said
we look into the sky and all that we see
is a result of and god said
we're children of the most high because
of the living transforming world and god
said
in the name of jesus dear god forgive us
where we've fallen short
forgive us for placing one day above the
bible south
for us for not forgiving those who've
hurt us their god even though we
understand an unforgiving person cannot
be saved their god the determination not
to forgive is so great people are
willing to go to hell rather than
forgive
change their father
change that right now
someone needs to forgive perhaps someone
needs to apologize
and somebody needs to make a decision
to be baptized or re-baptized
father i'm about to make another call i
won't be long
let your spirit make the proper
conviction i pray
if there's someone who needs to forgive
someone
can i see your hand
you need to forgive somebody i'm going
to pray for you right now keep your hand
up
dear god
you see the raised hands
they've raised the hands as the holy
spirit has moved them with the impulse
of honesty they need to forgive someone
give them that grace now give you that
strength not to wait or to feel like
forgiving but to obey forgive one
another give them that strength that
they will leave this church and
immediately start the process to say i
forgive you
hands down someone listening to me needs
to apologize to someone whom you have
hurt you've hurt someone you've done
someone something wrong you've never
apologized if that is you raise your
hand
you need to say sorry to someone you've
heard i see those hands i see them i see
them i'm praying father i see hands
raised saying i need to go tell someone
i'm sorry
please god
give them that grace
give them that humility and give them
the power of jesus to go say i did thus
and so and i am sorry let them do it
regardless of how they feel
now father my final call
someone needs to make a decision to be
baptized
or realized if that is you can i see
your hand
a decision to be baptized or re-baptized
if that is you
raise your hand let me see
father in heaven
we thank for this hand has raised
in the name of jesus dear god secure
everyone who's made a decision a
decision to forgive secure that a
decision to apologize secure a decision
for baptism secure that their god
and i believe this consecrated building
let us remember
and god said
must be the anthem of our lives it is
written that's how jesus lived that's
how we must learn there is only glory of
god that intimidates the devil he is not
intimidated by church membership he's
intimidated by believing in truth
father
let other words have spoken in my big
way
have an effect on those who listen
online and in person
let this day forward be the day when we
mark a change in our lives i pray
from my heart
in jesus name let god's people say
amen and amen
[Applause]
[Music]
you